what time of day was it when you watch  in your house was in the afternoon so  the first thing you did was start  cleaning your gear you didn't like sit  on the couch and say man I need to I'm  gonna have a beer and talk to my what  does that say to you it is it's and it's  a lifestyle - you know you got to get  ready for the next fight so I mean clean  your gear get it ready get it prepped  for the next mission and then that's all  done and finally cleaned up then I can  go in and turn to and hang out and relax  so and how long did it take to clean it  ah I don't know depending on how long  the machine was going for for - washing  all the clothes and stuff like that but  uh I took a probably but a day